happy friday everyone i love fridays
not that time hasn't all melted into
each other but i still hold fridays in
very high regards
and i'm so excited that you're all here
i hope everybody has fun weekend plans
even though the week and the weekend are
not that different anymore
but i'm really excited because i'm gonna
have a little
um sleepover like safe coven safe
we're in a pod together uh they work
here on the show with me and we've
been extremely close nearest and dearest
for
well over 20 years actually and it's my
friend's birthday it's actually two of
my friend's birthday lee harris
and robin frederick
and we're just gonna do my favorite
thing pig out
watch tv take some long walks it feels
like a slice of
well normal so bffs you look fantastic
how do you like to spend your birthday
let's see miriam and charlie hmm
a little crown you look so pretty
thank you she's turning 10 years old
today
oh my gosh today how fantastic
happy birthday i have to tell you drew
her full name is charlotte drew ryan
anya are you no after you
oh my gosh oh
i'm so honored to be a part at small
park i have been one of my biggest
inspirations throughout my life
so oh my gosh well
i hope to continue to live up to that
and that means so
much to me because you know i don't know
sometimes people will say like i don't
want to say i'm proud of you that sounds
patronizing i'm like oh no no i'll take
it
we are so proud of you thank you
well i will keep it up and happy
birthday to your beautiful girl
i am this is just so wonderful